President Trump insists there is unity
in the Republican Party despite intense
criticism from some GOP senators
politics is our up business is no
question about it I will say this I
think the Republican Party has a pretty
good unity Republican divisions could
put more of the president's legislative
agenda in jeopardy that includes perhaps
his most prized priority tax reform the
house plans to vote today on the
Senate's budget bill that would clear
the way for tax reform that proposed tax
plan is expected to be released on
Wednesday major Garrett's at the White
House major good morning good morning
president Trump has made sport of
criticizing fellow Republicans mr. Trump
has called out 1/5 of the Senate
Republican Conference for one reason or
another and as we all remember
Republican divisions helped sink
Obamacare repeal Republicans are going
to try to hold it together on tax cuts
but that will take some doing because
there are disagreements for example some
top House Republicans want to lower the
maximum amount you can put into a 401k
retirement account tax-free the
president said earlier this week quote
there will be no change to your 401k
well now that's open for negotiation the
president also wants to eliminate tax
deductions for state and local taxes but
more than 50 House Republicans from high
tax states may well object and we still
have no idea the income levels for
future tax brackets or whether there
will be three tax brackets or four and a
new poll shows 35 percent of Americans
say they do not have any confidence in
Republicans or Democrats to take care of
taxes now House Republicans have
promised Charlie some clarity on all
this by releasing their tax bill next
week thanks major